those black friday shoppers were hit in
the stores early this morning victoria
saha joins us live now from one of the
go-to locations in downtown summerlin so
victoria how was the turnout
yeah not your usual crowd like you
normally see everyone just rushing in
all at once to get their hands on those
best deals but shoppers are still making
their rounds here
downtown summerlin mall was officially
open at 8 a.m but several big box stores
let customers in earlier in previous
years black friday usually looked like
this and last year many folks chose
online shopping instead because of the
pandemic this year a rush was expected
by shoppers like rachel warren but they
got a nice surprise when they showed up
i thought we were going to run into big
wines big crowds i only had to wait a
couple minutes outside lush just because
they were at capacity but it's been a
really nice day we've gotten into every
store we wanted to get into officials
here say they're expecting around 100
000 shoppers in the area today that's up
30 percent from last year
i also spoke with the manager at one of
the pop-up stores here she says a lot of
the stores started their deals earlier
in the week which helped avoid that
massive rush of people all at once
reporting from downtown summerlin
victoria saha live local now